vie précaire destin cabossé existence
déracinée aujourd'hui encore à la barre
les victimes se sont raconté des passés
difficiles auxquels se rajoute
aujourd'hui la douleur d'être un rescapé
quand d'autres ont péit j'ai des amis
qui sont
morts c'est ça ça ça se défile comme ça
leur visage là j'arrive pas à les
oublier j'ai envie de pleurer mais
j'arrive pas et tout ce que je garde ça
me fait mal il y a un avant et un après
incendie une cassure de plus comme la
cliente de maître Garcia qui a dû
extraire de l'immeuble ses trois enfants
seul elle ne parvient toujours pas à
comprendre pourquoi son mari qui dormait
dans la chambre d'en face ne l'a pas
aidé elle ne lui fait plus confiance
quant aux enfants ils vont mal c'est
plus aujourd'hui que la plus grande a
des difficultés euh il y a de nouveau
des éurésies la nuit elle a du mal à en
parler elle ne veut pas aller voir le
médecin et le second euh qui aujourd'hui
est très agressif parce qu'ils sont au
courant que le procès a lieu
actuellement dans le box des accusés on
le sait les deux cousins n'ont pas eu
une enfance facile mais les victimes ne
leur adressent ni un regard ni une
parole chacun est muré dans sa douleur
j'ai été élevé dans une famille
d'accueil depuis l'âge de 22 mois comme
j'ai dit comme j'ai ditlé euh ça
j'aurais pu devenir un euh bah un petit
merdus en présence masculine et puis je
suis pas devenu euh non non ça explique
pas tout non non ces deux derniers jours
les accusés sont restés le dos voûé
visage inexpressif ils n'ont quasiment
jamais osé lever les yeux vers les
victimes qui à la barre revivaient la
nuit où toute leur vie a basculé remémy
kulanski et Nicolas dostreille sont
conclus en présentant une nouvelle fois
leurs excuses mais ces mots sont vides
sont creux leur répètent les avocats des
partis civiles si vous nous dites pas
qui a mis le feu à la poubelle cette
nuit-là mais les cousins continuent à se
rejeter la faute des de ment c'est sûr
mais on ne saura sans doute jamais
lequel